after nearly three weeks of evidence
we've heard in court for the first time
from former officer derek chauvin
is this your decision not to testify it
is your honor
all right do you have any questions
about your right to remain silent or to
testify on your own behalf
not at this time i don't right does
anyone uh
promise anything or threatened you in
any way to keep you from testifying
no promises or threats your honor do you
feel that your decision not to testify
is a voluntary one on your behalf
yes it is as expected derek shoving
chose not to testify in his trial
for the murder and manslaughter of
george floyd
the defense has now rested its case
arguing george floyd
died of several factors including drugs
and a heart condition
with a final rebuttal the prosecution
recalled a witness
to speak to derek chauvin's knee on
george floyd's neck
what they argue was the cause of death
as soon as you put pressure here you can
immediately sense
that your upper airway is narrowing
the trial is now playing out in the
backdrop of protests
sparked by the death of another black
man by police
twenty-year-old dante wright killed in a
routine traffic stop
by officer kim potter who claims she
fired her handgun instead of her taser
by accident george floyd's family lawyer
is now representing the wright family
too unbelievable that
the police woman killed a
another unarmed black man
while the derrick chauvin trial
regarding the killing of george floyd is
going on
cannot believe it if ever there was a
time in america
where they should be de-escalating it's
now
the outrage over these two deaths by
police have converged in minneapolis
the courthouse and much of the city now
locked down
and boarded up there was already a heavy
security presence here
for the trial but that has visibly
stepped up
since the shooting of dante wright on
sunday and the nightly protests that
have followed since
there's a real concern here that things
could only escalate
by the time of verdict the outcome of
one of the most important
criminal trials in u.s history now
hinges
on 12 jurors who we expect to begin
deliberations next week
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis